مثل الملايين من مواطنيه حمدي
كان ملتصقًا بتلفازه عندما سجل ساليك
بهدوء ركلة جزاء في الدقيقة الأخيرة
ضد الكونغو ، حيث أرسل الذهب مصر
إلى نهائيات كأس العالم لأول مرة
منذ عام 1990 ، مما عزز مكانة سالاس
كبطل قومي وأرسل شوارع
القاهرة إلى النشوة.  أنا عن
المنتخب الوطني ، أعني بوضوح أنك
ستجعل الرياضة سأكون
مندهشا للغاية إذا لم تكن
لاعبين جدد معًا
معظمنا في نفس العمر نلعب معًا في
فريق وطني أقل من 21 عامًا وتحت 17 عامًا.
لذا تذكيرات من في مجموعتك ،
نعم ، لدينا صوت مسموع وروسيا صحيح ، لذا
فإن السعوديين يلعبون مع الروس في
المباراة الأولى في ليلة الافتتاح
ثم تلعب مع أوروجواي ،
لذا يمكنك التأهل إذا سألتني
رأيي لن أقول يمكننا أن أقول.  نحن
نتأهل لك ، بالطبع سيكون لديك
مجموعة صعبة لكننا نذهب
بثقة وأنا متأكد من أننا مؤهلون